at the center of every great tournament
it is its prize trophy and the iconic
fifa world cup is here tonight alongside
with the global icon who has lifted the
kofta trophy in 1998
please join
please join me in welcoming hublot's
friend of the brand and the 1998 fifa
world cup winner of france mr marcel
dusselly
as we commence in tonight's celebration
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
and what keeps you up at night
sometimes we may face challenges
and to those that say you can't
and you won't succeed
we say watch
a journey that we have been on together
for the past 10 years
other dreams of welcoming the world
and now our dream is becoming a reality
every single person who has worked
every minute and every second we are
getting closer and here we are
all gathered together
look around you
we are all here to prove one thing
and to witness
are you ready to count down the days
[Music]
are you ready now
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen please welcome back
to the stage mr dosai accompanied by
captain sami tarabisi head of coach
qatar stars league and el celia team and
qatar legacy ambassador adel jamis for
the unveiling of the clock
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
are you ready now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
honored symbolism our remarkable clock
counts down the kickoff of 365 days
filled with challenges excitement and
hope
your highnesses your excellencies
distinguished guests
we thank you all for being a part of
this incredible moment in this
incredible event
um
may we now welcome to the stage our
following guests for the official
photographs with the trophy and the
countdown clock
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
well there we have it the ceremony there
to unveil the clock that is now counting
down
365 days to kick off of the
2022 fifa football world cup here in
doha qatar
365 days but gemma
there's still a big test event coming up
for six of the stadiums and the coming
days i believe yeah absolutely we have
to wait another year for the world cup
but uh we don't have to wait as long for
the fifa arab cup that gets underway
next tuesday and this is really seen as
a kind of vital operational trial for
the world cup um organizers are get
gonna get the chance to test hotels the
teams are staying in transportation
routes police escorts and just general
operational readiness of the stadiums
and six of those stadiums in use for the
fifa aircraft will be the world cup
stadiums
there are three world cup stadiums still
to be inaugurated
two of those will be inaugurated at the
arab world cup next tuesday on the
opening day we've got al bait that's
going to be inaugurated on tuesday when
qatar play bahrain
and then on the same day stadium 974
i'll explain a moment why it's called
974. that will also open its doors for
the first time when they um host united
arab emirates and syria now it's called
stadium 974 because it's made out of 974
shipping containers and 974 being the
international dialing code for qatar so
those two stadiums to be in operation
next week and then the final world cup
stadium to be inaugurated will be
lucille stadium that's the biggest of
all the venues and 80 000 capacity
that'll be inaugurated in early uh next
year so and also interestingly the final
of the arab cup is on the 18th of
december so it'll be exactly a year to
the day that the fifa world cup final
will be played so it's going to be
interesting to see for the organizers
and the fans and everybody involved how
uh the arab world arab cup plays out
well i'm moving on from the arab to
talking about the world cup again and
let's bring in ap's global sports
correspondent rob harris from london
rob thank you for joining us so i think
it's fair to say it was a surprise to
many when qatar was awarded the
tournament way back in 2010 and how far
has qatar come since then
yeah it was 11 years ago i was in zurich
for that huge fifa vote not only
awarding the 2022 world cup but 2018 as
well and certainly when qatar's name
came out of the envelope announced by
seplata later it would
send shock waves around world football
not only the fact the first world cup to
go to the middle east beating such big
nations in terms of status perhaps as
well and you know including the united
states but of course so small um never
such a tournament being staged in a
country like qatar and it required
obviously such development work such
infrastructure upgrades and
such intrigue over how a country the
size of cats i could host the world's
football fans and teams for a tournament
and for fifa very much taking football
and its main tournament to new frontiers
and we saw the shots of the fifa
president johnny infantino earlier from
fifa's point of view how significant is
it that the tournament is coming to the
middle east for the first time
well obviously it has been a very
fraught decade or so since the awarding
of the world cup
corruption investigations have taken
place into indeed many of the bids of
which qatar was at the center of the
investigations in the end
fifa's
investigator concluded there was nothing
in terms of the content that warranted
stripping qatar of the tournament but
then
subsequently as well the challenge
caused by the economic and diplomatic
boycott of qatar by the uae saudi arabia
and others posed
the challenge to the tournament
infantino at one stage though still
wanted to try to spread this tournament
beyond qatar and actually bringing some
of the neighbours into the hosting
logistically that that was not possible
and probably in infantino qatar has
found quite a supporter someone who's
acted to defend the tournament who's
particularly highlighted changes to the
labor laws that are taking place without
scrutiny from human rights activists as
the country has been developed activists
still saying actually the implementation
of some of those reforms needs to go
further but infantino has certainly
spent a lot of time going around the
stadiums in recent days as well in
particular and
after the challenges of tournaments like
brazil in 2014 south africa in 2010
about whether infrastructure would be
ready the fact qatar could say this
weekend that all stadiums already all a
to them will be a source of assurance
for fifa with one year to go
absolutely and qatar are 51st in the
world at the moment but they are the
asian champions of course should the
other countries be aware of them at this
time next year do you think i'm thinking
maybe perhaps to south korea in 2002 and
they co-hosted with japan they i think
surprised everybody um finishing fourth
so do you expect the same kind of thing
next year
well certainly yeah the team will be
needing that home support the home lift
it's always a real challenge for a host
nation the fact that they don't
necessarily have competitive games
in the years building up to the
tournament because of qualifying as
hosts what is so unusual about this
world cup is qatar
that debut at the world cup will be at
its home tournament and
there was that astonishing win in the
asian cup uh almost three years ago now
which would have surprised some people
because one of those things talks about
when qatar did win the bid as well it's
not a country with football heritage as
we've said obviously there has been a
league going back many decades in a
national team indeed
qatar has had managed to play
more recently in europe i've actually
tagged on to a qualification group
feature in portugal but the results
haven't been that encouraging at least
there was a two order with azerbaijan in
the recent internationals but looking at
those games losing four nil to serbia
four nil defeat to ireland three no
defeat to portugal it's a reminder
actually of the challenge but
we've seen in so many competitions that
the so-called underdog can galvanize
themselves to
you know to perform but i don't think
this is a world cup that is necessarily
going to be reliant on the host nation
doing well in the sense that it's such a
rare opportunity for so many of the
world's
biggest players and teams to come into
qatar that actually it should actually
get the fans locally coming in and
giving the size of the country to fans
will be able to catch games if they can
get tickets when their own team isn't
necessarily playing even maybe with a
couple of games a day
and just very quickly rob this will be
the first world cup held in november and
december didn't go down too well with
the european leagues uh initially do you
think that's been put to bed now
well there are still some grumbles about
the disruption to the european leagues
next season but this was actually agreed
in 2015 there were meetings in doha
between fifa the leagues and various
other officials as well in the game
and
the irritation will come from the fact
that when qatar did bid for the world
cup in 2010 it was a june and july
tournament promising air-conditioned
stadiums which have actually been
delivered on we saw them at the world
athletic championships in particular in
2019 but qatar didn't have the option of
bidding for a winter world cup that
became more realistic option after the
vote and then all sides coming together
and actually managing to
realistically move the tournament so
it's actually better for fans because
although the stadiums would have been
air conditioned in june july the heat
would have been pretty difficult in
terms of traveling around the country
but
that's the thing facing sport
particularly in the years to come and
with climate change too that probably
needs to be an accommodation to allow
countries that can't host a olympics or
a world cup in their traditional slot to
move it around and
the disruption
isn't that significant for one year to
be able to host the tournament in a
different region and maybe for countries
like england who often complain about
having to go to a tournament at the end
of a gruelling season in june going in
november means the players perhaps
should be less weary at that point and
actually get into their peak absolutely
well thank you so much for your insights
there rob back to nostalgia thanks so
much gemma
well let's take you live back to the
corniche where that ceremony has been
taking place in terms of the unveiling
of the clock our correspondent dorset
jabari is there a dorsal we saw
alongside fifa president jenny infantino
the casualty royal family there as well
it really seems to reflect just how
significant a moment this is for qatar
and it goes well beyond sports here
yes certainly this was not an event just
for regular people there was certainly a
heavy uh royal presence uh one of the
reasons we couldn't move around freely
was because of the presence of royal
guards here
it shows how important this certainly is
for this country this is a major win for
the royal family since they were awarded
this event into 2010 now it's over a
decade and they are one year away this
was certainly seen as something they
were looking forward to many even locals
were looking forward to this
they now have less than a year to go
before they will host the world cup here
we saw a very famous
french footballer marcel de saying who
got on stage and kicked a football
to start off the clock he brought the
actual trophy of the world cup and
placed it behind me on stage where it
will stay until the tournament is done
and is awarded to the next
winner the next country who wins the
world cup in 2022
this is seen as an event that really
will
put qatar on the world map even further
than it has already the country has
spent 6.5 billion dollars on improving
its infrastructure and built seven new
stadiums for this event and they're
expecting over a million people to come
to this tiny country now just to give
you an idea the smallest country to ever
host the world cup was switzerland in
1954 and at that time there were 16
teams taking part in the world cup there
is now 32 teams and qatar will be
certainly smaller it's three times
smaller than switzerland and they will
be hosting 32
teams from around the world so it's
going to be interesting how they will
facilitate that number of people but
they've certainly been trying to prepare
as much as they can um building hotels
at very rapid rate here and they hope
that it will be enough and
accommodate all the people that they
will have coming into this country
of course dorsey you mentioned the 6.5
billion dollars worth of infrastructure
there that didn't just go to stadiums in
qatar but a number of other things as
well i also understand that this is
supposed to be the the greenest world
cup ever
can you briefly talk us through what's
what's been prepared in terms of getting
ready for the tournament
certainly one of the stadiums will
actually be completely dismantled and
donated to a country that is in need of
sporting infrastructure and aside from
that there will be 170 000 seats from
the stadiums they will take apart and
that will also be donated to another
country or any of the countries that are
in need
to improve their sporting infrastructure
there's also the way the stadiums have
been built there's a german firm hired
for that and they were they were adamant
the cultures were adamant that there
needs to be a sustainability aspect to
all of what has happened of course this
world cup is significant because it's
the first time the
fifa federation has agreed to change the
time of when this competition is being
held usually it's held in the summer but
because of the severe weather here they
are now they've moved it to the winter
in november and into december and the
stadiums that have been built will all
be air-conditioned as well to take in
the factor of the temperature in this
country so there's been a lot of
attempts by the locals here to try to
make it as green as possible
and everyone clearly getting very very
excited about what's to come dorsa
jabari they're live for us on the doha
cornish